bonjour une grande première médicale en
france
je vous le disais en titre pour la
première fois deux maires ont mis au
monde deux enfants qui avaient été
fécondée artificiellement et dont
l'embryon avait été congelé pendant un
certain temps
c'est une grande première médicale
enfants ce qui ouvre des perspectives
illimitées à la science car on peut
imaginer bien sûr qu on congèle des
embryons pendant des années et des
années pourquoi pas et qu'on les fesses
ne fasse naître beaucoup plus tard des
naissances identique avait déjà eu lieu
à l'étranger en france c'est la première
fois martine amanieu je vous propose de
voir tout de suite
sarah j'espère qu'on va voir maintenant
la voilà la voilà alors sahara est né le
20 février dans la plus grande
discrétion il y à un mois et demi elle a
été fécondée sans doute un an plus tôt
et voici maintenant guillaume qui est né
dimanche dernier 6 avril un garçon et
l'ifi absolument norme au nez de leurs
propres parents et qui sont en fait deux
beaux succès de la maternité antoine
béclère à clamart que dirige le
professeur papiernik et/ou coopère le
clinicien rené frydman et le biologiste
jacques testart alors on entend souvent
parler d'un côté des femmes stériles
deuxièmement des cliniciens je dirais
que là il ya une grande part de biologie
qui se passe hors de l'organisme et qui
a permis d'avoir des embryons non lésés
bien congelés qui donnent naissance à
des bébés norme permet de s'extasier
alors une grande première donc martin un
agneau qui vaut bien sûr de grands
espoirs à tous les parents qui ont des
problèmes de stérilité mais qui pose
aussi beaucoup de questions et c'est
pourquoi nous reviendrons très largement
sur ce sujet dans une dizaine de minutes